aaron richards four and four his earned
run averages three point eight eight so
now guerrero jr 3 29 18 homers 48 runs
batted in he's tied for the major league
home run lead who are hugging at home
plate i've never seen that well we're
going to hug every night what's going on
you don't see this every day huh from
the 1-2 pitch
and guerrero laces it to left field and
off the monster on the fly to shed
around second digging for third and in
there ahead of the throw
on a bullet of a single off the monster
for guerrero and let's see if the blue
jays can get a run or two here against
richards and the red sox one two again
and t oscar lines it to right field for
a base hit that'll get beshet home
guerrero's going to stop at second on
the rbi single and the blue jays strike
early
well one down they are all filled up and
riley tell us 213 with three home runs
but he has long been a red sox killer
that's a bullet in the center closing on
that making to catch hernandez and a
runner has to stay put look at this
throw
as guerrero jr couldn't go anywhere
that is unbelievable the guerrero came
down the line and then decided to go
back and tag up by then it was too late
but even if he's tagging up he's not
going to be able to score on that no
playful nudge there from
rapid there's guriel 255 with five home
runs bases loaded swag and a miss he
struck him out richards
somehow someway holds the blue jays
to just one run they leave him loaded
ross stripling he's two and three with a
four seven one earned run average
alex verdugo to climb into 285 with
eight home runs make some nice defensive
plays he'll drive that one to left that
one's headed off the very top of the ten
back to guriel he takes a real wide turn
trying to get back and he's in a rundown
and it's thrown away that's gonna skip
up against that fence right in front of
the red sox dug out he's all the way
down to third diving in
oh what a gift right there he had second
thoughts but he waited too long he's
halfway to second and he's a dead duck
at first
he's dead duck it's second and he's also
at first base both places
but then they throw the ball all over
the ball pocket he's able to make it to
third base that ball bounced right up
into the glove of guerrilla junior out
there and just a bad throw to first base
celeste couldn't block it
and badugo continues on it's one out and
a runner at third
2-2 and a fastball right down the middle
for strike three called and a big second
out richard's a long look into vasquez
now has the sign maguire at second two
down
and the two two
and a buchet sends one up the middle and
into center a base hit maguire around
third hernandez comes up throwing the
throw is not in time
and a bushette will take second on the
play it is two to nothing blue jays well
what a great attack by bow and [ __ ]
comes up throwing and makes a pretty
strong throw but
maguire slides in the throw is a little
bit off line two on with two out and the
inning continues
and hernandez sends one to left field
and this is going to be off the wall on
the fly
the chet will come in to score stopping
at second guerrero on a long fenway
single by hernandez and it's now three
to nothing here's bobby dalbeck
high fly ball here by dalbeck deep to
center sailing back and kiss that one
goodbye
into the stands for a
seventh home run of the season for bobby
and the red sox are on the scoreboard
that makes it three to one boy he has
struggled off right-handed pitchers but
not now
gets a fastball when he hits them
they're just no doubters and this being
one of them two [ __ ] and got two out
so vlady
he's probably thinking about taking a
pitch here
you know what and he lines it to left
field and off the monster again and it
cares away from verdugo over towards the
foul line
and vladi's got a double and he's been
on base all three times tonight two down
and now te oscar hernandez he's had a
good night he's got a couple of rbi
singles already
as the three and four hitters gary
richards hasn't gotten either one of
them out yet tonight
hernandez swings at the first pitch fly
ball to right field
ren throw there and that'll be that here
comes rowdy teles
all one hammered up the middle that's
where they haven't played
gonzalez taps and goes on to first for
the twin killing
double play
two down in the fifth i'll tell you that
beat goes on here for garrett richards
he's up man two gone but a man in
scoring position toronto ahead three one
if ten hits and a one strike pitch now
to bidgeo
he hits it on the button but it'll get
to arroyo quickly and he fires on at
first base
chris
taking over now this guy vladie guerrero
what a night he has had
oh two pitch hit high in the air deep
left center field
gone vladie's big night continues as he
hits a bomb over the monster for a
two-run homer
just the second home round body is hit
here at fenway and he came into this
game tonight with a 207 career average
here at fenway and he is
pumping up those numbers i mean that was
a shot runner third two down
3-2
and lined in the left center field for a
base hit rodulgo finally into score on a
renfrow stings one the red sox get their
second run tonight two out of the bottom
of the sixth and charlie montoya has
turned it over to tyler chatwood
base is loaded here comes
and he missed with ball four and that
forces in a run
and the red sox continue to chip away
i'm telling you beautiful thing ball
four
and i'll say this
this crowd is influencing this
performance oh yeah
he's got too much movement he he hasn't
got a cross seamer to save his life it
all moves
all the way to the backstop here comes
vazquez breaking he will score
the runners move up to second and third
it's 5-4
red sox have the tying run 90 feet away
the go-ahead run at second now you can
take a shot
take a shot
maybe you'll lay it try to lay it in
there and you lay it out of here
and it drills him and that's gonna load
the bases again
three batters faced two of them hit one
a walk lead down to one mesa coming in
and mesa comes in to face [ __ ] hernandez
one two pitch and a weak ground ball
maze has got it throw to first in time
and mesa gets a huge out runners at
second and third two down and a one-two
from taylor
swing struck him out
but a tremendous job by taylor
to freeze them in scoring position but
charlie montoya was asking for one
enormous out out of carl edwards jr here
in this spot the tying run is out at
second with two down one two again and
he got him swinging
carl edwards junior strikes out hunter
renfrow and the blue jays still have a
lead at the end of seven christian
arroyo has flied out two times also been
hit by a pitch
swinging a high fly ball that one driven
deep to left there it goes it's gone
the second night in a row for christian
arroyo oh he's styling the whole way now
and he has tied it 5-5 so toronto has
loaded him up here in the ninth inning
in a five-five tie with two down riley
adams
swinging a ground ball deep short
gonzalez will sling it close play
red sox get out of the inning
on a close play
and the red sox are on the doorstep of
pulling off another come from behind win
nobody out dolis would have won two
swinging a high fly that one heading
back toward the wall
it's going to catch the green here comes
santander rounding third and the red sox
walk it off
and a knock off toronto
six to five
what a w
what a gift w